ellen road the home of leeds united
before kogud 35 000 used to pack the
stands every weekend
now that's the number of people being
infected with the virus
in england every day that's the
conclusion of the office for national
statistics which
randomly tests tens of thousands of
people every week whether or not they've
got symptoms
of all the stats we get these are the
ones to pay attention to
across england 433 000 people had the
virus last
week that's up from 336 000 the week
before
and it works out at one in every 130
people
being infected but there are big
regional variations in the southwest is
about one in 300
in the northwest it's one in 59 that's
one person
on every busload other data suggests the
official r number is down marginally on
last week to somewhere between
1.2 and 1.4 suggesting the epidemic is
still
increasing but a little more slowly one
senior scientist warns
more restrictions will be needed to
reverse the rise
tier one is probably not
sufficient to control the epidemic
and i suspect that many areas that are
currently in tier 1
will at least move into tier 2 over the
coming
weeks our analysis of other stats
suggests that
students may be masking a background
epidemic in some cities
this is manchester divided as the whole
countries into small areas each with
just a few thousand people in them
we identified where the university halls
of residence were and then
tracked the second wave to start with
all parts of the city saw a gentle rise
in cases
but when the students arrived the
infection rate in university areas
exploded then as thousands isolated in
their flats
cases fell almost as fast but meanwhile
cases in non-student areas are still
steadily increasing
it's a similar picture in sheffield and
liverpool and nottingham
to a lesser extent and that's a worry
non-student areas have an older
population
with an increased risk of serious
disease
that suggests there is little hope of
admissions to hospital
easing in the next few weeks if the
number of new cases doesn't start
falling
soon they'll be increasing pressure to
take even stricter measures
to control the virus thomas more sky
news